[MUSIC]
My mother started as a first year student
at the University of North Carolina in
1972.
That would not have been possible had
she been born just a few years earlier.
For most of its history,
UNC was an exclusively male institution,
like many universities.
And while we've come an incredible
long way from there,
sexism is still alive and well.
Indeed, it's living in our language.
Now, I'm not talking about words that
were designed to denigrate women.
Bitch, whore, slut.
I'm talking about seemingly innocent
words, words that we hear every day.
Perhaps we even speak them.
Mankind.
Man made.
Or popular here at Stanford, Chairman.
Fellow.
Male centered words are everywhere.
We're taught that all
men are created equal.
We man tables and
use our manpower to elect Congressmen
who rule in man made institutions.
Man.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We laugh, but I'm
really concerned with these associations
due to our unconscious beliefs.
How does the perpetual association of
male terms with power and with strength,
and female terms with insult and
with weakness shape our expectations for
men and for women, our expectations
of our self, or even our self worth?
Children can help us understand
just how powerful language can be.
My niece, Ella, is five years old.
She has three older brothers,
and I was babysitting for them.
And so I asked them what do
you guys want to do tonight?
Ella was silent.
A little later as I was tucking her
into bed she looked up at me and
she said Uncle Win, how come you only
wanted to know what the guys wanted to do?
Why didn't you care about me?
My heart sank.
Of course,
I wanted to hear what she had to say.
I love Ella's opinions.
Sometimes, I love Ella the most.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I never meant to suggest
that she didn't matter, but that's
exactly what I had done through my words.
And thank goodness she
said something to me.
When I had said you guys to her,
she took me literally.
And quite logically, she felt left out.
How often had she felt that way before?
How many of you have ever felt that
way before, excluded by language,
even if you knew that that
wasn't the speaker's intention?
Male-centered words are everywhere.
When you flip the words around,
how many men do you know that feel
flattered to be called a woman?
Right?
Douglas Hofstetler is a philosopher.
And what he does is he replaces in
a satire male-based generic words
with race-based ones.
Mankind becomes whitekind,
freshman becomes freshwhite,
chairman becomes chairwhite.
And in this imaginary world, it becomes
pretty ridiculous that we would ever
expect people of color to feel included by
these terms, or that these terms wouldn't
have real and lasting consequences, things
that reflect are pretty gruesome history.
But that's exactly what we do.
It's what we do to women,
and it's what I did to Ella.
Of course, some women, and
many women do feel included by these
terms, and that's entirely understandable.
Women who become congressmen for
example, work incredibly
hard to get where they are.
They overcome enormous obstacles.
They earn the title.
When women don't feel included,
I've heard them speak up and
then I've watched the eye rolls.
I've listened as they get
labeled high maintenance,
overly sensitive, or much worse.
When we use female words to insult women,
we communicate a pretty disturbing
message, and we communicate the same
disturbing message when we use only
positive words with male terms.
Sociologist Sheryl Clyman
explains that when you use
chairman for women, yes,
a particular woman can become a chairman.
But women as a group cannot.
Chairman sets expectation
that chairmen are men.
And when a woman achieves that title,
she's merely an exception.
Never the rule.
Rarely the expectation.
When we use male based generics,
we erase women linguistically.
Symbolically, annihilate them.
Now, there's a visionary who I love,
Marilyn Frye, and she imagines all of
this gender inequity as essentially
a birdcage that traps women inside.
There are many, many wires to the cage.
One wire is the wage gap.
Another wire is sexual harassment.
Another one is men's
violence against women.
And there's sexist English.
The point here is that there are many,
many wires.
And these wires,
no wire by itself traps the bird inside.
It's all of the wires working together
in combination that creates a prison.
We can break that prison.
With so many wires I often get
asked why focus on language.
Aren't there other wires
that are more important?
Let me be clear, every wire is important.
Every wire deserves to be broken and every
wire that we break creates a new opening.
I like to single out sexist language for
three reasons.
The first reason is that everyone
has the power to break this wire.
It's entirely within our control.
Each of us decides constantly
what words we're going to say,
what we're going to type in
a text message, put in an email.
What language displays on our websites or
goes in a official publications
that we put up there.
Language is a choice
that we make constantly.
It's our choice.
The second reason is that we
can break this wire right now,
you don't have to wait.
It's so
much easier to start saying you all today
than it is to close the wage gap tomorrow.
Though, of course, we should do that, too.
The third reason is that
gender inclusive language
is inclusive of everyone, even men.
It doesn't harm anyone when
you switch to inclusive terms.
Instead, it proactively signals
your commitment to women.
And what more powerful message to send.
I want to acknowledge that while
this solution is really simple,
that doesn't make it easy.
Male dominated words are everywhere.
They're deeply embedded in our culture.
Getting rid of them requires intention,
it requires unlearning.
It requires a community to
hold one another accountable.
So let's do this together.
Let's stop using gendered words and
replace them with gender neutral options.
Freshman becomes first year student.
Chairman becomes chair.
Arbuckle fellow becomes Arbuckle coach or
scholar or leader.
You guys becomes you all.
Or if you're like me from the South,
y'all.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Language is a tool of thought.
It's a tool for building community, and
it's a tool for breaking birdcages.
Each of us has the power to create
the world that we want to be in.
So do we want a language that
reflects our history of excluding and
diminishing women?
No.
Do we prefer a language that aspires
towards something much more inclusive for
our future, for our mothers,
our sisters, our daughters, our nieces?
Your decision to become a gender
savvy speaker is a decision
to build this world,
a world that takes women seriously.
Sheryl Clyman teaches that inclusive
language is the resource that each
of us has at the tip of our tongues.
Let's start tasting its freedom today.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]